Welcome back to the David Pakman show.
I'm Benjamin Dixon filling in for David while
he was away on vacation.
Thanks so much for having me yesterday.
And we're having an um, I would say a good
time today but the stories today are so heavy.
This, this particular story has a messing
with me since um, since I read it in the BBC
is reporting that immigrants were forced into
solitary confinement, uh, for being disabled
mentally ill are gay and um, I just want to
read a couple of the stats that embassy reported
on six detainees committed suicide while in
confinement.
One detainee was held in solitary for 11 months
and another for over a year, some 390 days
in confinement.
Um, the whistleblower in this case stated
that ice claims, ice immigration, customs
enforcement claims that they only use this
as a last resort, but she witnessed how this
was used as a first resort and how it was
used on people with mental illnesses.
And in many cases they were merely acting
out based on their mental illness.
And yet instead of getting them, um, treatment,
medication, getting them to see a doctor or
whatever their particular case required, they
put them in solitary confinement.
Um, they claim that it's for safety reasons.
Um, but in many cases the detainees were acting
out simply based on their illnesses.
And somebody pray till please tell me what
safety reasons are you going to put a person
into solitary confinement because they're
gay.
Um,
okay.
Ice is literally, actually before I even finish
that sentence, I had the backup.
Some of this took place underneath the Obama
administration.
It's been happening for the last five years.
So for five years we have been putting people
into solitary confinement leading to the suicide
of at least six detainees that we know of.
And I'm sure that there are more than that
at this point.
All because we have this fetish we fetishize,
uh, we, we have this, this an ordinate fear
of not even fear, hatred of immigrants.
And we, we do, we do.
It's almost like a fetish that we have to,
that we have to capture them and we have to
punish them and we have to make them go through
every terrible thing we could imagine just
so that they can be worthy enough to begin
the process of a citizen or a resident.
So this has been happening longer than the
Trump administration, but the very worst has
been happening under the Trump administration
because while I needs to be abolished and,
and Barack Obama was the deporter in chief,
there's an element to this, a level of insidiousness
and a level of cruelty that is attached to
this because of the nature of this president.
And because of the nature of the people he
surrounds himself with, like Steven Miller
who have, uh, an obscene hatred for immigrants
and have this, this laser like target on the
backs of every brown immigrant that comes
to this country and they enjoy this cruelty
or is Adam Sir of the, the, the, I believe
the Atlantic says the cruelty is the point.
No.
What I was going to say a few moments ago
is ice is truly acting out on all of America's
fascistic tendencies.
I mean, we like to think of ourselves as home
with a free in the land of the brave and whatever.
I probably mixed that up.
Uh, whatever we like to think of ourselves
in that way.
But in all actuality, throughout American
history we have been brutal authoritarian.
I mean fast cystic.
We have intern people.
We started this country on genocide.
We built this country through slave labor,
wi Wi.
We exacerbated the, the, the criminalization
and the other vacation of black people through
Jim Crow and all the way along the line we
in turn Japanese people doing world war two.
I mean we have a, there are so many crimes
that show you what America really is.
And now to add on top of all that, we are
treating people, lobbying them into concentration
camps, for lack of a better word, based on
the fact that they're mentally ill, they're
disabled or they're day.
I mean this, this, we don't like to draw comparisons
with Adolf Hitler and we don't like to compare
anything to the Holocaust.
Right?
The soul.
Yeah.
But this reminds me of a playbook straight
out of my account.
Like this is a straight out of the Nazi playbook
of, of, of, of purging.
I mean, how's the, how else can you see this?
It's almost like ice.
Like I was laughing about this earlier, but
it's like we just need to put an s at the
end of ice and go ahead and call them isis
because of things like this, because of the
number of people were dying in their custody
because of the way they're carrying out their
policies because of the way they are.
They're draconian fashion.
Like they're cut throat, their cruelty, their
cruelty for no reason.
No justifiable reason.
None, none whatsoever.
I don't know how this story's going to end.
I don't know what the result of this whistle
blower is going to be.
But one thing I can tell you for certain,
it shines a light on the fact that this country
that we like to claim is so beautiful.
And this country that would like to claim
is so free, has at its core a fascistic leaning
that if we're not careful, we will be in a
nation that we never thought this nation could
be.